I think about who they could have been
and what they would have been like and
so yeah those were our future children
future children that are now gone
Kate plants and the others we spoke with
stored their frozen eggs and embryos at
University Hospitals in Cleveland
so you trusted that your your eggs your
embryos would be safe at the hospital
here yeah we've learned yeah you never
imagined this would happen no the eggs
and embryos were stored in a freezer
tank at University Hospitals which was
equipped with a remote alarm system that
should have alerted an employee to any
temperature change but the hospital says
the alarm was off so an alert was never
issued and the lab wasn't staffed
Saturday night so the temperature in the
tank continued to rise causing the
embryos to thaw we take full
responsibility for what has happened we
are very sorry that this happened
this is a catastrophic event for
patients problems filling the tank with
liquid nitrogen may have thrown off the
temperature University Hospital says at
least 4,000 eggs and embryos were lost
impacting 950 patients what did you lose
that day I lost my reason for being
alive really starting a family was
really kind of all I had as far as a
purpose now I'm never gonna know what
those babies they're gonna grow up to be
Thanks that's what I lost it's just like
the hope for my future and not knowing
like if I'm going to build and now have
kids to preserve the opportunity to have
a child attorney Jack Lance kroner is
suing University Hospitals on behalf of
about 180 families he represents an
investigation for the Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services found
that the very same storage tank
experienced a malfunction in the filling
mechanism and remote alarm system back
in January the tanks manufacturer denies
it's equipment malfunctioned the
hospital then neglected to take the
necessary steps to repair the concerns
that were raised months before this
incident ever occurred nor did they make
your clients their patients aware this
they made no disclosure to the clients
who had eggs and embryos stored at this
facility that they were having problems
and an a a pattern of malfunctions if
the hospital has already admitted wrong
doing why the lawsuit well I think our
clients want answers and they really
haven't gotten them yet we're suing for
what the law allows which is for
compensation for our clients for what
they've lost and also ideally to have
changes made that will allow these
systems to be safer University Hospitals
declined our request for an interview
citing pending litigation but in an
e-mail they told us that patients are
their first priority and they're working
to improve operations at the fertility
clinic still that won't help these
families they lost all their eggs and
embryos and can hardly think about the
painful process of going through IVF
again for some that's not even an option
so that was our only chance to have
biological kids because both of my
cancers were estrogen based and so to
pump me with more hormones to get more
embryos is out of the question